hey guys I want to talk about a
confusion that relates to yogurt versus
kefir right number one yogurt really
only helps you clean the colon and
provides food for the existing microbes
that are in the colon already it does
not provide more bacteria into your
colon so it cleans the colon it provides
food okay that's it on the other hand
kefir which is a different product but
similar does a lot more it actually
helps you grow new colonies of friendly
bacteria it helps you grow new colonies
of friendly yeast yeah I know you have
friendly yeast in your body when you
don't have enough from the east you get
the unfriendly yeast and Candida is a
type of yeast so you can get these
infections you can get these problems in
the private parts you can have problems
in overgrowth like the white tongue
syndrome you can have unfriendly yeast
in your enlarged intestine so there's a
lot of different issues that can happen
so keeper has a lot of different strains
that you can set back into your deep
areas of your colon to start to rid the
unfriendly bacteria and unfriendly yeast
so it cleans it up it's pretty cool
especially in the deep mucous membranes
of the body the other thing that's
interesting about kefir is that it adds
more nutrients to the body
way more than yogurt so it actually
increases tryptophan which is amino acid
that helps sleeping that helps your
cognitive state it helps anxiety it
helps even cravings to chocolate because
tryptophan turns into serotonin which is
a which is the hormone tryptophan is
basically amino acid so that's why in
your gut there's a lot of connection
between your gut and your brain so if
your gut is doing well you're going to
your moods going to be better you're not
going to have as much anxiety you're
going to feel calmer very important but
if you have a lot of digestive issues
good luck now the other thing is that it
will provide calcium magnesium and
phosphorus b12 vitamin b1 so there's a
lot of great nutrients kefir is much
easier to digest so it's really good for
an in
pintor a baby and also the elderly okay
much easier to digest than yogurt also
yogurt is pretty pretty high in sugar
and then also kefir is the best remedy
for Candida that I know about so if
you're going to consume either one of
these I would do this one here you know
you don't need much and small amounts
make sure it's plain make sure it's not
low-fat make sure it's whole milk and if
you have an allergy that could be a
problem so find another way to do it but
keeper is a really good product to help
your digestion thanks for watching
hey guys thank you so much for watching
please click the subscribe button and I
will see you in the next video